c'est un parfum bim eau sauvage terrains
de la zac est ce que tu as fait pour moi
ce matin restera gravé sur le marbre de
mon coeur toujours au nom de la fille il
a le coeur dans les mains là qui tu vas
voir ce soir ça va être aussi beau que
les galeries lafayette tu vas te raser
entièrement comme une femme tu va
glisser dans l'eau comme un savon dans
la prison vous êtes trop magnifique
mademoiselle suffit vous êtes belle à en
crever un coûteux il nettoie toujours
son instrument comme les américains tués
elle comme on dirait dans les nouvelles
télévisuelle une victime collagène comme
quoi la victime collatérale j'ai tout
rangé la réserve élémentaire est
impeccable j'ai tout fait comme un petit
tournions mon âme est bien que je
t'accorde connaît